[Musique]
depuis plusieurs semaines la CGT
Castorama revendique une revalorisation
salariale plusieurs actions sont menées
dans plusieurs sites de l'enseigne de
bricolage à Strasbourg Xavier Gaspard le
délégué syndical a démarré une grève de
la fin hier à 13h aux Clayes-sous-Bois à
Marseille Saint-Loup à Reims et à
Béziers les salariés ont décidé
d'occuper plusieurs magasins toute la
nuit dernière pour la suite les salariés
ont appelé à la grève aujourd'hui et
d'autres nocturnes sont prévues dans les
87 magasins restants en France 500 c'est
le nombre de jours restants avant le
début des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 pour rappel les
jeux démarre en France le 26 juillet
2024 et plusieurs sites les
accueilleront dans le département des
Yvelines on peut citer notamment le vélo
Drôme et le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines ou encore le
château de Versailles pour les épreuves
séquestres et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore acheté leur place sachez que les
inscriptions pour la seconde phase de
vente des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
démarre demain mercredi 15 mars jusqu'a
[Musique]